in previous videos we started talking
about the idea of transformations in
particular we talked about rigid
transformations so for example you can
you can shift something this would be a
translation so the thing that I'm moving
around is a translation of our original
triangle you could have a rotation so
that thing that I translated I am now
rotating it as you see right over there
and you can also have a reflection the
tool that I'm using doesn't make
reflection too easy but that's
essentially flipping it over a line but
what we're going to talk about in this
video is a non rigid transformation and
what makes something a rigid
transformation is that lengths between
points are preserved but in a non rigid
transformation those lengths do not need
to be preserved so for example this
rotated and translated triangle that I'm
moving around right here in fact I'm
continuing to translate it as I talk I
can dilate it and one way to think about
dilation is that we're just scaling it
down or scaling it up so for example
here I am scaling it down that is a
dilation or I could scale it up this is
also a dilation or even get going off of
the graph paper so the whole point here
is just appreciate that we don't just
have the rigid transformations we can
have other types of transformations and
dilation is one of them in your toolkit
that you will often see especially when
you get introduced to the idea of
transformation